if you look at some of the wealthiest
people in the world you look at Warren
Buffett why does he still get up and
work like you have all the money in the
world you're I mean you can literally
just fly around in your private jet and
just do the most exotic things in the
world why do you not do that all day
every day and never have to stress about
money ever well he likes what he does he
likes researching companies he is he
gets a certain excitement out of that
that you don't get out of doing other
things and so for him it's it's that
matter of purpose and you look at like
you know an easy example to see is just
look at shark tank you have these sharks
on Shark Tank why are they there they
don't need more money right they're they
enjoy entrepreneurship they got to where
they were because they were
entrepreneurs that entrepreneurial
energy is something that you want to be
around and so now you can help other
entrepreneurs and go back into the
entrepreneurial energy another million
dollars when you have 100 million
dollars doesn't change your life it
doesn't really affect you at all